[موسيقى
] أصبت بالشلل في أبريل 2013.
لقد استيقظت فجأة ولم أستطع
الشعور بساقي ، لذا أجروا الكثير من الفحوصات
والتصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي ثم
عادوا وقالوا إنك تعلم أنك
مصاب بورم في المخ  بالإضافة إلى حالة عصبية ،
إنه وقت مظلم مثل
الظلام حقًا وما زلت أعاني من الاكتئاب الآن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[تصفيق
]  اكتشفت أن الراعي
قد أحضر لي بدلتي الخاصة
[موسيقى]
لذلك سأذهب كل يوم
وأقوم بالأشياء التي كنت أستطيع
القيام بها قبل أن أصاب بالشلل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[تصفيق] تدور
حياتي الآن حول تحقيق أكبر عدد ممكن من
التحديات وكوني
أول شخص مصاب بالشلل يحقق
ذلك وعندما يقول لي أحدهم أنك لا تستطيع فعل
ذلك ،
فسأفعل ذلك على أي حال
فقط لإثبات نقطة أنه لا
يوجد شيء اسمه تهدئتك